today I'm not going to ask you to do
something very difficult all of you have
a piece of chocolate in front of you if
you don't I want you to pick up that
piece of chocolate and I want you to
leave smell it
think about how good it would taste if
you were to take a big bite of it after
unwrapping it but you can't eat and I'm
going to ask you not to eat the
chocolate
for the next ten minutes because for the
next ten minutes as much as you might
think about how good it would taste or
how delicious it would meet we're going
to talk about willpower now what do I
mean by the time willpower is our
ability and what we use to override our
default design our default desire of
what we want to do in a situation right
now that would be for me eating the
chocolate right in front what many of
you may be the same thing that why am i
up there talking about willpower it
seems like a pretty normal thing for us
to happen
well because much of what society tells
us about willpower is that it's an
innate trait you are a driven person
you're a motivated person the last 15
years of science have told us that
that's not necessarily the right way to
think about willpower and the reason
this is important to me is that
willpower informs everything that I try
to every chain
in fact willpower is critical to change
because it involves overriding or
default overriding eating the chocolate
in America 27 percent of people say that
will lack of willpower is their biggest
barrier to change I'm sure many of you
can think of examples of how that has
affected your life things you've wanted
to change or maybe some things that your
friends have wanted to change so what
I'm going to share with you today is a
new way to think about willpower some of
the recent research that's gone on about
how we would understand well power with
some illustration of dark chocolate and
I'm also going to share with you
practical tips on what you can do to
augment your willpower
so the first thing I'll give to you is
that willpower should be thought of as a
muscle it's like every other
physiological system the neurobiology of
the brain is very similar to the biology
of a muscle willpower can be depleted
willpower can be exhausted you need to
maintain it with rest give it time and
it can be strengthened with practice so
let me go through each of those in turn
first willpower is exhausting if I have
you sit there with the chocolate in
front of you for the next 30 minutes
can't eat it sitting right in front of
you you can't taste it and then I asked
you to go and solve a very hard math
problem you would last half as long on
that math problem as a group of 60
people that I pulled from the courtyard
over there what use willpower is an
expendable resource between activities
so if you expend a lot of willpower
resisting the chocolate sitting in front
of you right now
you won't have as much of it to deal
with the hard math ecology much like a
runner who's completing two marathons in
a row the second point I wanna make is
that rest and fuel make a difference to
willpower for those of you who didn't
eat breakfast not having that chocolate
right now may be a difficult task but
that's not just because you're hungry
blood glucose levels if they're low make
you twice as likely to be the person who
unwrapped that chocolate then the person
next to you and if you didn't sleep last
night you're up to 25 percent more
likely to unwrap that chocolate than the
person next the other consequence of
this is that when you're not rested or
you're not or you're having happen or
you haven't eaten at the end of the day
perhaps you're hungry at night when
you're fatigued this will tend to cause
you to give up on many things that you
wouldn't otherwise when your freshly
fueled in the morning the last point I
want to leave with you is practice makes
it stronger like a muscle that you work
out on a regular basis if you took that
chocolate and you stare at it for ten
minutes each day let's say I'm not gonna
eat this and you can did that for two
weeks at the end of two weeks you would
see benefits in your ability to quit
smoking people report benefits in their
ability to make better grades then if
it's an exercise benefits in keeping
with the dieting these have been studies
done with all sorts of heart activities
writing with your non-dominant hands for
five minutes makes a difference if you
do it every day for two weeks
changing your exercise routine even if
you exercise exactly the same amount
just doing something different
overriding your default makes a
difference after two
so with my time remaining I'd love to
share with you a couple practical tips
about how you can use this understanding
of willpower as a muscle to change what
you do in your life and therefore first
and not necessarily obvious identify
what you are going to use your willpower
on pick your battles because if that
chocolate weren't sitting in front of
you right now you'd probably have an
easier time resisting it and the math
problem I would ask you to solve
afterwards
you wouldn't be depleted in a lot of
people think if you don't think the
willpower is a spendable resource you
don't know about that concept you'll
tend to do activity after activity and
wonder why you can't keep doing the hard
stuff when you get to the end of the day
so pick your battles
the second thing like the muscle of you
gets exhausted so take place you sitting
there for 10 minutes with that chocolate
in front of you affects your ability to
do the math a hard math problem
afterwards but if I give you a
five-minute break in between your
ability to last on that math problem
it's completely restored so if you've
got hard tasks take breaks in between
this is also not just something for
yourself and how to change your own life
but how to change the lives of others if
you give somebody in your work
organization a hard task multiple hard
tasks accept the fact that they might
need some that you need to take a break
in between them because that's gonna
enhance their ability to complete third
rest and fuel are important to willpower
them so make sure you're well rested and
fuel if you're going to be doing hard
legs it's as simple as getting a good
breakfast in the morning and not
depriving yourself of sleep or meals
when you're trying to get stuff done
give yourself a little bit of space and
finally blessing practice I gave you a
couple of examples today a couple of
examples on ways in which you can over
time build up your real power because
willpower is something that all of us
are going to need to change the hard
things in our lives and that other
people around us will need to change the
hard things in their lives and this kind
of practice whatever activities you
choose to do will enhance your abilities
to get the big things done thank you
very much for resisting for the last ten
minutes and you can now